like having one hour on the clock i feel  like he he he just fell too quick i mean  he played too quickly and yeah  and and this is i think once again it  will sound maybe a little bit harsh but  uh you know this is why he is now 25 85  when he was at some point 2700 very  solidly and  was a very you know deservedly a 2700  player  uh because when he's not having a good  day he you know switches to this mode of  just playing very very quickly and  kind of trusting his hand and you know  trusting  uh trusting into the the higher powers a  little bit too much  i guess like if we if we if we are to  continue actually talking about the  position  i guess you play queen h4 here  and hope that somehow this doesn't lose  on the spot  um and i want to at least put the other  rook on e8